welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John matus and I'm the technical director for education at IBM
Quantum this is the 12th lesson in the series and it's the last lesson in the third unit which is on the general
formulation of quantum information this lesson is centered around a fundamental notion in Quantum information which is that of a
purification of a Quantum State a purification of a Quantum State represented by some density Matrix is a
pure state of a larger compound system that leaves us with the original state when the rest of the compound system is
discarded or traced out every density Matrix has a purification and we can learn a lot
about Quantum States and about Quantum information in general by studying purifications at an intuitive level
Quantum State vectors which represent pure states are simpler mathematical objects than density matrices and by thinking about
purifications of States we're able toew arbitrary Quantum states of systems as being just parts of something larger but
simpler we'll also talk about the Fidelity between two Quantum states which is a value that quantifies their
similarity or overlap and it's often used as a way of measuring how good a particular state is as compared with
some ideal state in particular we'll discuss the definition of fidelity along with some of its basic properties and we'll see
how Fidelity connects with purifications here's an overview of the lesson we'll start with purifications including the
definition and a simple proof of their existence which tells us how to find one if we need one then we'll discuss something known
as the Schmid decomposition of a Quantum State Vector of two systems and we'll see how Schmid decompositions relate to
purifications then we'll discuss a critically important relationship between any two purifications of the same state which is known as the unitary
equivalence of purifications and finally we'll go through a few examples we then turn to Fidelity
including its definition and some of its basic properties we'll talk about the gentle measurement Lemma which is a very
handy fact that ties Fidelity back to measurements and finally to conclude the lesson we'll turn toan's theorem which
establishes a fundamental connection between Fidelity and purifications let's start with the
definition of a purification a purification of a state which assume is represented by a density
Matrix is a pure state of a larger compound system that leaves the original state that we started with when the rest
of the compound system is traced out we can express this more precisely in mathematical terms as
follows if we have a system X that's in some State row meaning that row is a density Matrix representing a state of X
and S is a Quantum State Vector of a pair of systems XY such that tracing out y from the pure State C side bro plus I
leaves us with row then we say that s is a purification of row naturally the names don't matter we
can name our systems and our states whatever we want and The Ordering of the systems also doesn't matter for example
if the system y was on the left rather than on the right but everything else was the same we'd still refer to SAI as being a purification of row but we'll
mainly stick to this setup for the remainder of the lesson just for the sake of Simplicity and the first thing to say
about definition is that purifications always exist for every density Matrix row and to be more precise every density
Matrix row has a purification like the definition describes provided that the system y is at least as large as X which
is to say that y has at least as many classical States as X the notion of a purification and the
fact that purifications always exist turns out to be critically important and it's also part of what makes Quantum information beautiful and hopefully I'll
be able to convince of that fact by the end of the lesson now let's prove that every density metrix has a purification and in
the process we'll see how we can get our hands on a purification when we need one just like we had in the definition
of a purification let's suppose that X is a system and row is a density Matrix that represents a state of
X now consider any expression of row as a convex combination of pure States as we have written on the screen in words
for some choice of of a positive integer n we have a probability Vector p 0 through PN minus1 as well as Quantum
State vectors 5 0 through 5 nus one and by averaging the corresponding pure States weighted by the probabilities we
obtain Row for instance we could use the spectral theorem to obtain an expression of row like this and if we did that we
could take n to be the number of classical states of X in fact we could take n to be the rank of row which is
equal to the number of non-zero won values of row counting each one a number of times equal to its multiplicity and
that's never larger than the number of classical states of X but it could be smaller on the other hand this doesn't
have to be a spectral decomposition of row and we don't need these Quantum State vectors to be orthogonal for instance any expression of row like this
is fine and here's a purification of row the sum ranges over the same values as
in our expression of row and inside of the sum we take the square roots of the probabilities multiplied to F A tensored
with k a here by the way we're assuming that 0 through n minus one are classical states of the second system y so it
makes sense that s is a Quantum State Vector of the pair XY like in the definition it's not actually important
here that we use standard basis states of Y in this expression you could substitute any orthonormal collection of
states in place of K 0 through Kat n minus one if you wanted to and now we can check that this is indeed
a purification by Computing the partial Trace over y here's an expression of the state that we get by performing the partial trace
the trace of k a bra B is either one or zero depending upon whether or not a is equal to B and so the expression
simplifies to our original expression of row and it's a simple as that so it's very easy to get our hands on a
purification as long as we have enough classical states of Y or alternatively a large enough orthonormal set to use in
place of the standard Bas of States cat 0 through cat n minus one and by the way if the number of
classical states of Y is smaller than the rank of row then there won't be a purification and I'll leave that for you
to ponder if you choose to do that here's an example let's consider
the density Matrix that we saw several times in the lesson on density matrices here we have an expression of this
density Matrix as a convex combination of pure States it's not a spectral decomposition but we don't
care and with almost no effort at all we can write down a purification of the state by following the
recipe that's not the only purification of this density Matrix purifications aren't unique but that's okay the
definition doesn't say anything about uniqueness and in fact there's a very interesting relationship among different purifications of the same state but
we'll discuss that a little bit later in the lesson next we'll consider Schmid DEC compositions which are expressions of
bipartite quantum State vectors in a certain form that I'll describe momentarily they're named after aard
Schmidt the same Schmid known for the Graham Schmid orthogonalization procedure but in the case of Schmid decompositions they probably shouldn't
be named after Schmidt it's actually mathematically equivalent to something called the singular value decomposition for matrices which is something that was
actually rediscovered multiple times but that does happen sometimes but anyway here's what we mean
when we refer to a Schmid decomposition for an arbitrary choice of a Quantum State Vector s for a pair of
systems XY it's always possible to write s in a special form that form is as we
have here on the screen where R is some positive integer p 0 through p r minus one are positive real numbers that
together form a probability Vector x0 through XR minus1 are unit vectors corresponding to the system X and y0
through y rus1 are unit vectors corresponding to the system y now that might not look particularly
special until I tell you that both of the sets x0 through XR minus one and y0 through y Rus one must be
orthonormal so why is that special well if we were to pick any basis for one of the two bases let's say
the X vectors which correspond to the system X then we could always express s in this form and that would force us to
select the Y vectors in a particular way in fact we do this pretty routinely like we do with a standard basis when we're
setting ourselves up to analyze a standard basis measurement but in general even if we choose an orthonormal basis for the X
vectors the Y vectors we get aren't necessarily going to be orthonormal similarly if you picked an
orthonormal basis for the Y vectors and you tried to express s in form again you could but again the X vectors wouldn't
necessarily be orthonormal and finally if you did pick orthonormal vectors for both systems and
you tried to express s in a form like this it wouldn't necessarily work because you might find yourself in need of some cross terms but there's only one
index in this sum which is a so the form is special but it is always possible to
write a given unit Vector s like this and here's how you can do it first compute a spectral decomposition
for the reduced state of either of the two systems it doesn't matter which but for the sake of describing how this is done let's look at the reduced state of
X so we're tracing out y so that means that p 0 through p r minus one are igen
values of this reduced State row and x0 through XR minus one are unit IG vectors corresponding to these IG values and by
the way the understanding here is that we're ignoring the terms for which which the IG values are zero because those terms don't contribute anything to the
sum and that is to say that p 0 through p r minus one are all positive real numbers and R is the number of non-zero
igen values counting multiplicities which is equal to the rank of row so that gives us p 0 through p r
minus one as well as x0 through XR minus one and all that's left is to find the vectors y0 through y Rus
one there's only one choice that can possibly work those vectors are uniquely determined at this point and they can
easily be found using the simple formula that's shown on the screen and what's amazing here is that
if we Define these vectors in this way then they are guaranteed to be orthonormal and that gives us a Schmid decomposition I won't argue that in this
video but it isn't too difficult and you can consult the written material for the lesson in case you're interested check
the video description for a link as usual as an example let's consider this
Quantum State Vector which we obtained as a purification of the density Matrix example that we keep coming back
to it isn't a Schmid decomposition because the zero and the plus States aren't orthonormal but we can find one
using the procedure that I just described the first step is to compute a spectral decomposition for the redu
state of X which is that same example of a density Matrix and here's a spectral decomposition I of it which we saw back
in lesson 9 so we choose p 0 P1 x0 and X1 as is
shown on the screen p 0 and P1 are the igen values of row and x0 and X1 are
corresponding unit igen vectors and so it remains to compute y0 and y1 and if we do this we get cat Plus
for y0 and -1 * Kat minus for y1 that's not immediate you have to
actually do the calculation to see it but that is what we get and as expected those two vectors are orthonormal as
they will always be if you've done the calculations correctly and that gives us a Schmid DEC
composition Schmid decompositions are very handy in many situations and shortly we'll see what they tell us
about purifications purifications aren't unique a given Quantum State represented
by a density Ma will in fact have infinitely many purifications there is however a close
relationship that always holds between any two purifications of the same state and it's sometimes called the unitary
equivalence of purifications here's how it works let row be a density Matrix
representing a Quantum state of a system X and suppose that we have any two purifications of that state that are
pure states of the same compound system so so for the sake of concreteness let's suppose that s and fi
are quantum State vectors of a pair of systems XY that both give us row when the system Y is traced
out what the unitary equivalence of purification says is that there must be a unitary operation U that acts only on
the system y that transforms SII into fi in other words although these are
arbitrary purifications of row and we don't assume anything about them except that they both purify row and they're
both states of the same compound system XY they have to be equivalent in some sense up to a unitary operation on y
alone we'll see a few examples that illustrate why this is interesting and what implications it has but first let's
see why it's true let's begin with a spectral decomposition of row which is the
density Matrix that both SII and fi purify and just like we did when we discussed the Schmid decomposition we're
going to assume that we've thrown away all of the terms corresponding to zero igen values so p 0 through p r minus1
are all positive real numbers x0 through XR minus one are orthonormal igen vectors of row and R happens to be the
rank of row and by the way just as an aside notice how often we're reaching for the spectral theorem at this point
it's an incredibly handy tool and in fact we'd be lost without it anyway now that we have a spectral
composition row we can compute Schmid decompositions of our two vectors just like before and they're going to be
almost exactly the same the coefficients and the X vectors are the same because they come from the spectral decomposition of the reduced state which
is the same for both vectors the only difference is that we may get different vectors for the second system for the
first Vector which is s we'll get one set of vectors y0 through y Rus one and for the second Vector which is f we'll
get a POS possibly different collection which we can call z0 through zrus one so we now have schmitti compositions
for our two vectors which look very similar except that the vectors for the second system may be different but these
are Schmitty compositions so these two collections are both orthonormal and so we can simply choose
a unitary Matrix U that sends ya to Za for each a you can always do that unitary
operations are in fact equivalent to linear maps that transform one orthonormal basis into another and if
these two sets don't happen to span the entire space corresponding to Y we can always extend them both to orthonormal
Bases using coincidentally the gr Schmid orthogonalization procedure and that is how the unitary
equivalence of purifications is proved in lesson four of the series we discussed the superdense coding protocol
which allows a sender to transmit two classical bits to a receiver by sending one cubit at the cost of one ebit of
shared entanglement so I'm assuming that you're already familiar with that protocol and the point of this example is to briefly
explain how it connects to the unitary equivalence of purifications remember that the way that
the protocol works is that Alice and Bob share an ebit or in other words a five plus Bell State Alice chooses to transform that
Bell State into any of the Four Bell States depending on the two bits that she wants to send and then she sends her
Cubit to Bob and he measures to see which Bell State he has notice that all four bell States
give us the same reduced state for Bob's Cubit which is the completely mixed state and in fact that's already enough
to conclude that super dense cating is possible all four bell States purify the completely mixed state so by the unitary
equivalence of purifications we know that it must be possible for Alice to transform the five plus Bell State into
of the others by applying some unitary operation to her Cubit of course it's not difficult to come up with unitary operations that
actually work and they're very simple but it's interesting nevertheless that we can reach the conclusion that this is
possible without even thinking about the unitary operations themselves and moreover we can conclude
that generalizations of superdense coding to larger systems are possible provided that we have some way of generalizing the Bell states to larger
systems so that they all give the completely mix State as Bob's reduce State and there are in fact different known ways to do
that a different setting to which the unitary equivalence of purifications has implications is quantum
cryptography and one of its most important implications is that it rules out the existence of an unconditionally secure Quantum protocol for a
cryptographic primitive known as bit commitment so what is bit commitment bit commitment is an example
of a cryptographic ative by which we mean a low-level task or procedure that provides some basic functionality which
can then be used as a building block to do more interesting things like creating digital signature schemes or building
zero knowledge protocols for instance in the case of bit commitment the basic functionality is that one
player Alice is able to commit to a binary value of her choice to a second player Bob but her choice remains hidden
until she chooses to reveal it we require two specific properties from a protocol that implements bit
commitment it must be binding which means that Alice can't change her mind once she's committed to a bit and it
must be concealing which means that Bob can't determine Alice's bit until she chooses to reveal
it so it would be pretty nice to be able to implement this primitive using Quantum information because it's a
useful primitive but without any additional assumptions it turns out to be impossible possible to do it perfectly with Quantum information or even close
to perfectly and the unitary equivalence of purifications reveals that the idea at a very high level is
that if there were a Quantum protocol for bit commitment then there would have to be a so-called purified version of that protocol where we can imagine that
Alice has a system a bob has a system B and after the commitment is made but before Alice reveals the pair AB is in
one of two pure States size zero or I one depending on the bit that Alice
commits if the protocol is perfectly concealing then it must be that Bob can't tell the difference between the
two commitments so his reduceed state must be the same for the two possibilities however that implies by
the unitary equivalence of purifications that Alice can transform either one into the other by applying some unitary
operation to a alone so the protocol completely failed to be binding there are details in there that
I've swept under the rug but the heart of the matter is that the unitary equivalence of purifications tells us that this primitive is not something
that we can reliably Implement using Quantum information without additional assumptions of some
kind the last example of an implication of the unitary equivalence of purifications is a theorem known as the
Houston Joseph wooders theorem or hjw theorem for short let's start with a statement of
the theorem itself and this is a slightly simplified version of it just to avoid some technicalities so that we can focus on the main
ideas suppose that X and Y are systems and F is any Quantum State Vector representing a pure state of the pair
XY and now suppose that we think about the reduced state of the system X alone and we come up with any way that we
choose to express this reduced State as a convex combination of pure States as is shown on the screen
so for instance the number capital N in this expression which is the number of pure States we're averaging over could
be arbitrarily large possibly much larger than the dimension of the space corresponding to X or to Y for that
matter and what the theorem tells us is that there must exist a measurement on the system y having n outcomes such that
the following happens when the system Y is measured first each measurement outcome
appears with probability exactly equal to the corresponding probability in our expression of the reduced state of X as
a convex combination of pure States and second conditioned on getting a particular measurement outcome the
state of X becomes the corresponding pure state from the convex combination so why is that
interesting well it means that for any way that we choose to think about the reduced state of X as a convex
combination of pure States there's some measurement of Y that effectively makes this way of thinking about the reduced state of x a
reality and what's remarkable is that this is possible even when the state f is chosen first and the convex
combination is chosen later as long as it's an expression of the reduced state of X there will be a
measurement of Y that works exactly like this so let's see how we can prove
this we start with two different expressions for the reduced of X which will give the name Row for
convenience next we introduce a new system Z whose classical states are the possible measurement outcomes or
equivalently the indices in our convex combination and now we can observe that the following two Quantum State vectors
gamma 0 and Gamma 1 which are both state vectors for the compound system XYZ are
both purifications of row and just to be clear when we're thinking about these vectors as being ifications of row we're
thinking about the systems Y and Z together as a single compound system that gets traced out to leave
Row the first Vector gamma 0er is essentially the same thing as the original pure State 5 except that we're
initializing the new system Z to the zero State it's clear that if we Trace out Y and Z we'll be left with row so gamma
0er is a purification of row the second Vector Gamma 1 is basically the vector we get by purifying
row based on the convex combination just like I described earlier in the lesson this time the system Y is
initialized and I'm assuming just for Simplicity that zero is a classical state of Y but you could substitute any
standard basis state or in fact any pure state of Y into this expression and it wouldn't make any difference in any case tracing out Y and
Z again leaves us with row so the bottom line is that these are both purifications of row and therefore by
the unitary equivalence of purifications there's a unitary operation U on the pair YZ that transforms gamma 0 into
Gamma 1 and that's all we need to come up with a description of a measurement that does what the theorem
says a simple way to describe it is with a circuit diagram like is shown here on the screen in words we start out with the
state F we introduce Z initialized to the zero State perform U and then measure the top system which is Z with a
standard basis measurement effectively what this does is to transform fi into Gamma One and
just by eyeballing the description of Gamma 1 we can see that this does what the theorem says which is that we get
each outcome a with probability PA and conditioned on getting a the system X is left in the state sa
a and just to be clear the measurement itself that the theorem implies the existence of is implemented by
everything in the dotted rectangle in the figure and if you want to know how the
measurement can be described as a collection of matrices here's an expression of them I won't explain this part and it's
not really important for the sake of the example but that is an expression of the measurement matrices in case you're
interested next we'll discuss Fidelity which is a measure of how similar two Quantum states are or alternatively how
much they overlap we'll start with the definition which might look a little bit mysterious at
first glance but we'll unravel it and by the end of the discussion I hope that I will have convinced you that it's
actually a much nicer function than it might seem at first glance and here's the
definition the Fidelity between two density matrices row and sigma is equal to the trace of the square root of the
square root of row * Sigma time the square root of row we'll talk about
it first let's just try to make sense of the definition itself we have three square roots and
they all refer to the square root of a positive semi-definite Matrix which as we discussed in the previous lesson is
the unique positive semi-definite Matrix that squares to give us whatever Matrix we're taking the square root of because
row is a density Matrix it must be positive semi-definite so we can take the root of it and if we think about theot of row *
Sigma theot of row for a moment we see that it's also positive semi-definite and in particular we can write it as
mger * M for M being theare root of Sigma time the sare root of row and therefore we can take the square
root of it in particular we can compute a spectral decomposition of the root of
row * Sigma * theun of row and then to take the square root we just need to take the square roots of the IG
values and leave the IG vectors alone and finally we take the trace of
this Matrix and because the trace equals the sum of the IG values we obtain the expression that we have right
here so that's probably something that you don't want to compute by hand in general and this explanation might not
offer very much insight into the Fidelity or why we care about it but hopefully it clarifies the technical
meaning of the formula by the way just as an aside sometimes people Define the Fidelity to
be the square of the function that I've defined right here and they refer to this function as the root
Fidelity you'll see it defined both ways which certainly has the potential to cause confusion but it usually doesn't
because people are generally pretty careful about making clear which definition they're using and you should
be sure to do the same thing to my eye there really isn't a right or a wrong definition I Define it
like this simply because I got used to doing it this way and I do find that it's a little bit more convenient I guess because I'd rather Square
something then take a square root later on when the need arises but of course you're free to make your own
choice but anyway let me get back to the Fidelity as it's defined here there are other equivalent ways to
define the Fidelity and it's actually a pretty remarkable function in that respect and it can actually be characterized in some pretty interesting
ways here's a pretty straightforward way to rewrite the definition in terms of the trace Norm which we saw toward the
end of the previous lesson I didn't go into too much detail about the trace norm and in particular I
didn't even Define it for non-h herian matrices but it does have a simple enough definition one way to define the trace Norm of an
arbitrary Matrix m is that it's the trace of the square root of M * m dagger or equivalently the trace of the sare
root of M dagger time M you get the same value either way you do it and we can use that definition to simplify the
definition of the Fidelity as we have down here on the bottom of the screen and that's nice because it reveals that
it's symmetric in the two arguments we can also Express the trace Norm of a square Matrix matx M as the
maximum of the absolute value of the trace of M * U ranging over all unary matrices U which is not obvious but it
is true and that gives us another expression for the Fidelity so here we have three
equivalent definitions for the Fidelity and that's just the beginning there are several other equivalent definitions and
we'll see a particularly important one which comes from man's theorem toward the end of the lesson
okay so that's fine but what does it all mean at an intuitive level and why should we care about this
function to answer these questions it's helpful to consider the special case in which at least one of the two density
matrices represents a pure state if both states are pure then the
Fidelity is simply the absolute value of the inner product between the two Quantum State vectors and in some ways
this is a principal motivation for the Fidelity itself the absolute value of the inner product between two Quantum State
vectors is always a number between zero and one and it gives us a natural way of measuring how much overlap there is
between two Quantum State vectors and you can think about the Fidelity as being a useful and well- behaved way to
extend this way of measuring overlap from Pure states to density matrices if one of the states is pure
and the other one isn't necessarily pure then again we have a simple expression for the Fidelity which can be pretty
handy and that expression is shown right here the Fidelity has many interesting
properties and that's one of the reasons why people use it it has a definition that isn't really
all that nice but it's a very useful function never less and it's often very easy to use in part because of its many
amazing properties so let's take a look at some of them starting with the observation that the Fidelity between two density
matrices is always a number between 0 and one it's zero if and only if the states
are orthogonal meaning that the images are orthogonal subspaces or equivalently that the product of the two matrices is
zero and the Fidelity is one if and only if the two density matrices are equal every other case is somewhere in
between but intuitively speaking the closer the Fidelity is to one the more similar the states are or alternatively
the more they overlap the Fidelity is also symmetric I mentioned that a few moments ago it's
pretty clear from the expression that we saw for the Fidelity in terms of the trace Norm but it's an important thing to recognize
nevertheless next the Fidelity is multiplicative for product States meaning that the Fidelity between two
product States is always equal to the product of the fidelities between the individual
states here's a really useful property if we have any two density matrices of the same size
along with any channel that takes these density matrices as input the Fidelity can only become larger when that channel
is applied to both States so in other words in terms of the Fidelity channels can only make States
more similar to one another they can't make them less similar and finally for this list anyway
there's a pretty close relationship between the Fidelity and the trace distance between states which is defined
as half of the trace Norm of the difference between the two density matrices the trace distance between two
states connects strongly to how well we can tell them apart which we discussed in the previous lesson in the context of
State discrimination and the hellstrom Holo theorem while the Fidelity quantifies how much two states
overlap so although they're not exactly the same thing it's not shocking that there is a relationship between these
two quantities but in any case these inequalities which are typically called the fuk Vander graph inequalities make
this relationship mathematically precise and it's pretty important that there's absolutely no dependence here on the size of the system we're talking
about we can see this relationship a bit more clearly with the help of a figure if we have two states and we
locate the trace distance between them on the x-axis and the Fidelity in the y-axis then the corresponding vertical
and horizontal lines must intersect somewhere with within this gray region the most interesting region of
the plot by the way at least practically speaking is the upper leftand corner of the gray region in particular when the
trace distance is very small the Fidelity must be very close to one and vice
versa these inequalities get used very frequently and part of the reason for that is that we often care more about
the trace distance ultimately because it has a natural interpretation connecting with Quantum State discrimination
but the Fidelity has so many amazing properties that it's generally the easier one to work with and as long as we're in the upper left hand corner of
the gray region which is often where we find ourselves we don't lose too much by converting back and forth between the Fidelity and the trace distance so those
are some of the properties of the Fidelity there's lots more but it's a good start and hopefully the list is
helpful for beginning to develop some intuition about the Fidelity here's a nice example of how we
can connect the Fidelity to non-destructive measurements it's a very handy fact known as The Gentle measurement
Lemma suppose that we have a system x a state of X represented by a density Matrix row and a measurement on system X
described by a collection of positive semi-definite matrices let's suppose that one of the measurement outcomes is very likely to
appear if we were to perform the measurement on the state row just for Simplicity let's suppose
that it's the outcome Z Z that's very likely and in particular let's assume that this outcome appears with
probability greater than 1us Epsilon for some small value of Epsilon that we don't actually need to specify Epsilon
is just some small positive real number now we've described our measurement as if it were a destructive
measurement but we do know from the previous lesson that we could implement this measurement in a non-destructive way and specifically we could do it as
we saw in our discussion of Neymar's theorem and that works like this each outcome a appears with
probability equal to the trace of PA * row and conditioned on getting that outcome the state of X changes in
particular in the case that we get the likely outcome zero the state becomes the squ otk of p 0 * row * theun of p 0
all normalized so that we get a density Matrix and what the gentle measurement limit tells us is that in this event
meaning that we do indeed get the likely measurement outcome the state we obtain will not have changed very much from the
original and in particular the Fidelity squared will necessarily be larger than 1 minus
Epsilon and this is great because this is completely General we haven't said anything at all about the measurement or
the state except that one of the outcomes is very likely so the Lemma can be applied in
many different settings where we'd like to verify something about a Quantum State without disturbing it very much so let's see how we can prove
it and for the most part it's actually a pretty simple matter of calculating the Fidelity between the pre and postmeasurement
States we can do this by using the original definition and ordinarily that might leave us with a messy formula but
in this case we luck out because the thing inside of the outer square root is actually the square of a matrix that
happens to be positive semi-definite which makes Computing the square trivial we can now use the cyclic
property of the trace along with the linearity of the trace to simplify our expression as it shown on the screen notice by the way that these are
all equalities so we haven't approximated anything at this point we're really just simplifying but now we do need an
inequality because we'd like to get rid of that square root in the numerator and we can indeed do that if we're willing to settle for a lower bound and if
you're interested in the details for this part you can get the inequality pretty easily by considering a spectral decomposition of p
0 the IG values of p 0 have to be between 0 and one that's always true for matrices that describe
measurements and once we know that the inequality follows pretty directly from the fact that taking the square root of
a number between 0o and one can only make it larger another way to say that is that squaring a number between Z and
one can only make it smaller we can now simplify just a little bit more and we we get the square
root of the trace of p 0 * row finally squaring both sides and
plugging in our bound on the probability gives us what we want so the formula for the Fidelity
isn't the nicest or easiest to use formula in the world but here it actually works pretty
nicely to conclude the lesson we'll take a look at alman's theorem which is a fundamental fact about the Fidelity that
connects it with the notion of a purification what the theorem says in simple terms is that the Fidelity between any two
Quantum States is equal to the maximum inner product in absolute value between two purifications of those
States in a bit more detail suppose that row and sigma are density matrices for some system X and suppose that Y is a
system that has at least as many classical States as X and therefore we're guaranteed that both of these states have purifications that are
quantum State vectors of XY we can then Express the implication of the theorem in the form of the equation
shown on the screen the Fidelity between row and sigma is equal to the maximum absolute value of the inner product
between F and SII ranging over all fi and S that purify row and sigma
respectively so let's clean this up and work with the precise mathematical statement going forward what we'll do now is to prove
the theorem but first it's worth taking a moment to appreciate that it offers us a pretty intuitive way of thinking about the
Fidelity it also happens to be quite useful in its own right for instance to prove even more interesting things about
the Fidelity to prove it we'll start with spectral decompositions of our density
matrices no surprises there once we have spectral decompositions it's easy to come up with
two specific purifications of these states but here we're actually going to play a
trick notice that in both cases we don't have a standard basis VOR as the second tensor Factor like we did earlier in the
lesson but rather we have the same Vector as in the first tensor Factor except that it has a bar over it and
that means the entry-wise complex conjugate of these vectors so in other words we're basically just taking a
second copy of the igen vectors but we take the complex conjugate of each entry and we'll see why we do that in a few
moments but it's not at all obvious that we should do this and that's why we call it a
trick in any case these are purifications of row and sigma respectively and that's true by virtue
of the fact that our igen vectors are orthonormal and therefore so are their entry-wise complex conjugates and now we can apply the
unitary equivalence of purifications which says that every purification of our two states can be obtained by
applying a unitary operation to the system that gets traced out for the specific choices of purifications that
we just made the unitary operations don't have to be the same for the two purifications
of course so here we're using the letter U for the first one and the letter V for the second
one so the point is that every purification of our two states can be written as we have on the screen for
some choice of unitary operations u and v and now we can take the expression
from the theorem and simplify if we plug in our expressions for F and S and simplify a little bit we
get the expression that's shown here on the screen now there are a couple of steps in there and I haven't shown the details
so you know what to do if you want to do it but let me mention that the reason why we chose the purifications as we did
was to allow this inner product to simplify in exactly this way and in particular we put the complex conjugates
in there so we'd effectively be able to flip around the inner products in the second tensor factor to get the specific
form that we have right here we're almost there now we can use the cyclic property of the trace along
with the spectral decompositions we started with to get this expression and at this point we can
employ one of the alternative ways of expressing the Fidelity using the trace norm and we're
done certainly there are details in there that I glossed over very quickly and it's the kind of proof that you
really do need to work through yourself to fully grasp but hopefully this gives you the basic
idea and as usual you can find more details in the written content for the lesson which is linked in the video
description and that's the end of the lesson which has been about purifications Fidelity and the connections between them and it's also
the end of the unit which has been about the general formulation of Quantum information I hope you will join me for
the fourth and final unit of the series which is on Quantum error correction thanks for watching